vasya de mi sorry for me at the rut
schenker Bay foul bay 09 fan club
they're getting psyched up for Borussia
Dortmund's appearance in the Champions
League final for them this is a dream
come true soon before this is the
greatest thing of all for a Dortmund
found especially because nobody expected
to tile you're gearing up is an optimal
coach who gets the best out of young
players that's optimal or soil klopse
young relatively inexpensive squad takes
the pitch at the last public practice
before the champions league final a
long-term strategy has allowed Dortmund
to develop players into stars for
example they paid just 5 million euros
for her bed live and of ski today he's a
star striker the club knows their
investments will take time to pay off on
the field and at the bank at the press
conference after the practice the team's
chairman said sound financial
decision-making is their priority then
Evita oils everyone who works with this
club knows that will never again run up
debt to achieve possible success each
staff member is committed to the team
the directive is clear but we don't have
any budgetary taboos we can do anything
but we have to earn it first the mrs.
Malloy fi dita singing toasters and an
array of other fan articles enables the
club to increase their revenue the club
has massively broadened its selection of
fan items clothing like scarves and
t-shirts are still best sellers and
loyal customers keep coming back
since I flew them that's really cool
buying this stuff because it really
makes you feel like a big part of you
belongs to the club the Swedish mafia
this is all so each year I get a shirt
and have it printed and get the logo put
on the shorts and socks too yeah we're
the paying members who ensure that this
kind of stuff is around all the time
exactly my father dortmund financial
manager Thomas czesc remembers what
happened after the national championship
win in 2002 the club nearly went broke
after borrowing to buy in top players he
paid back the debts in part thanks to
new sources of revenue I see some
lasagna fun when I started back in 2005
Borussia Dortmund had annual turnover of
3.6 million euros back then we didn't
have anything for women or children or
young people but viewed economically
there a really large consumer group was
because it is a course of coefficient
and fastened now the club is earning 30
million euros each year selling fan
merchandise but it's ultimately up to
the players to keep the books balanced
their salaries at a total of around 50
million euros are the largest line item
in the budget that's all hits it as
walls essentially what that means is
that the players pay can be varied by as
much as forty percent and it's linked to
their success on the field the more
successful we are the more they earn the
less successful the less they are
different induced fila if Dortmund wins
the Champions League ten million euros
more will drop into the club's coffers
but the fans are against pricey
superstars it's John thought I said I
already think we shouldn't be spending
big money you can stay on the same track
and continue to rely on younger players
humanoids etsy even if they don't get
the title the fans will still stay loyal
to their club and its strategy
you